hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
cell therapy needs a data driven and
certified cleanroom compatible co2
incubator
i am jennifer woods of labrutz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker mary
kay bates senior global cell culture
scientist at thermo fisher scientific
mary kay you may now begin your
presentation
well thank you jennifer and thanks to
everyone for joining us today
thanks again to lab roots for welcoming
me back about a year ago i gave a
timeless forum about the
about the critical incubation parameters
for cell therapy
how they affect cultured cells and the
effect that different incubator designs
can have on culture conditions
near the end of my talk today i'll
review a few of the points of those data
that i presented a year ago
but interestingly most of what i'm going
to talk about today is about the room
environment
and how that affects the co2 incubator
such that the incubator requires
additional safeguards beyond those in an
r d lab
also the co2 incubator can provide
documentation that helps ease your path
through regulatory audits
now before i go too far i want to say
that i understand that not everyone is
using a co2 incubator for cell therapy
production in a clean room but maybe
this information will help you as you
start to think about that transition
over the last year our team here has
spent a lot of time thinking about this
and a lot of this information is
reflected from talking directly with our
clients working in cleanroom settings
who are scaling out production so let's
begin with my agenda
i'll begin with an introduction just
reviewing the global growth of
regenerative medicine it's fun to look
at the excitement in this sector
then i'll talk about what are the needs
for clean room equipment
and that involves all the sorts of not
just
documentation but also cleaning and
disinfection what are the concerns for
working in a clean room and how is that
different from an r d lab
part three is about what makes a co2
incubator clean room compatible and this
is kind of the meat of the talk and i
think it's very exciting i hope you will
too
part four will be just reviewing like i
said some of the data that i presented a
year ago
showing how incubator performance
affects your end results
because it affects how your cells grow
and then i'll finish up with some
conclusions and a little summary of my
main points
so you know i think many of us when
we're working in the lab or the clean
room we get very focused on our work
which makes us successful but i think
it's important to take a step back now
and then and look at the big picture
so cell therapy has existed for decades
the first blood transfusion occurred in
1795
and cell therapy also includes plasma
platelets bone marrow donations
organ transplants the first organ
transplant was already way back in 1954
and i think a lot of us of course are
thinking about vaccines a lot nowadays
in this global pandemic but vaccines
immune stimulators like interferon gamma
monoclonal antibodies
biologics like insulin all of those can
be considered cell therapy or
regenerative medicine as well
the first monoclonal antibody was
approved in 1986
and when we think about cell and gene
therapy i think many of us think about
cancer applications in particular
but i always like to review that there
are many applications in cell and gene
therapy including many applications in
orphan diseases that previously really
didn't have a lot of hope so that for me
is an inspirational point about the
potential for cell and gene therapies
and all regenerative medicine
applications are protected projected to
grow in the next five years
cell therapies in particular with a
cumulative annual growth rate of about
27 percent
interestingly in these data stem cell
therapies are
separated out and they have a kind of a
comparatively low projected annual
growth rate of about nine percent
and if we split um the growth rate into
different applications
musculoskeletal disorders are actually
the highest sector and maybe that's a
surprise to some people
cancer oncology applications as we know
are projected to have the highest growth
rate at 24 percent but all of these
applications are projected to grow in
double digits over the next five years
and this growth is occurring globally as
regenerative medicine institutions are
distributed in regions all around the
world
north america does currently have the
largest share of those institutions but
they are
represented in every region and that's
exciting and even in this global
pandemic which has slowed so much
growth in in businesses around the world
we're still seeing growth in the number
of institutions around the world
so when we look at this growth what what
types of institutions do we see
um it may be surprising i think when
many of us think about
uh therapeutic institutions we think
about the large companies like lonza
takeda pfizer but those actually
represent only eight percent of the
total number
about 23 percent of these institutions
are non-profit and government academic
institutions
and the remainder the vast majority
about 64 percent are startup companies
in mid-size companies and this is where
the innovation is occurring
so what's driving this growth
well as we see in the pandemic diseases
are increasing globally and this
includes not just respiratory viruses
but also other diseases like cancers
diabetes heart diseases are all
increasing globally
another big part of what's driving this
growth and what we've seen play a big
role in developing these vaccines for
the sars covid ii coronavirus
what's driven that vaccine development
so fast is collaboration
large companies are partnering with
startups which is a great partnership
large companies can provide the
infrastructure and capability to these
startup companies
where startup companies are providing
the innovation that maybe large
companies
don't have access to so much
in addition academics and governments
are working with industry in ways that
they didn't in the previous century so
that's providing a lot of innovation and
new ideas
funding is increasing we're seeing
investors take notice as they look at
the the growth that i just talked about
and the number of institutions and the
interest in applications across these
sectors
we're seeing mergers and acquisitions
we're seeing licensing as large
companies license the innovation from
startups and so on
and finally and maybe most importantly
government regulations are becoming
easier as regulatory bodies work toward
harmonization
across the globe so that provides
confidence to companies so that they
know they can work to the same standards
regardless of what
region or country they're looking for
approval in
and governments are also fast tracking
approvals and we're seeing that not just
with vaccines but also with some cell
therapies obviously safety and efficacy
are paramount but
we can speed some of that documentation
processes and some of the review
processes that we as we've seen with the
vaccines at least in the united states
and europe
so
with that i will now turn to talking
about the needs for clean room and
equipment
so i always like to start with the
definition of gmp good manufacturing
practices i think many of us know that
gmp stands for good manufacturing
practices but why do we have gmp
the whole goal of
good manufacturing practices is to
ensure
that a therapeutic is safe and pure
that is effective and that is it is of
high quality and a lot of gmp is just to
ensure
that processes are repeatable and
consistent across lots and
across production
lines and i think of it as a way to
remove some of the natural human
variability from a system to kind of
control our natural human behavior to
want to maybe skip steps
so gmp are guidelines only they are
minimum requirements that a manufacturer
must meet
every process every company every
innovation cell therapy is different so
you know better than anybody else how to
implement gmp in your institute because
you know your processes better than
anyone else so these are not
prescriptive rules there can be multiple
ways to comply with gmp and gmp is
typically insured through an effective
quality management system so let's talk
a little bit more about that
so the main challenges for those of us
working in gmp institutions or under gnp
guidelines is first
controlled documentation
we know that creating and implementing
critical standard operating procedures
or sops is a huge undertaking
and
and all of those are critical to your
success and as part of that following
good record-keeping
um uh
good documentation procedures okay so
because
good um
poor record keeping is often a big flag
and an audit failure it's um so you have
to implement you not just have to have
those sops and the good documentation
procedures but you'll also have to
implement them
everybody working under gmp has to know
their responsibility they have to be
properly trained and that that can
include
repeated training refresher training
under quality management it's important
not just to have a quality management
system but effective implementation of
those elements can make or break an
audit approval
so effective implementation of a quality
management system can help you detect
and prevent quality issues they help you
prevent risks before they become a
significant quality issue and they help
staff to evaluate a potential risk to
the quality of a therapeutic process
as part of gmp the equipment choice and
acquisition is important because the
equipment is the center of your
production process so equipment must be
gmp compatible and it must meet the
performance criteria that were
established during the development of
the therapeutic in the process so if you
have great cell growth in your r d lab
you have to be able to duplicate that
great cell growth as you transition into
a gmp production process
so that laboratory equipment is the
center of your production and as part of
that
that equipment must be your gmp partner
so
the gmp equipment as i've already said
must meet the performance needs so that
the cellular product that you produce
meets the viability and quality
requirements that you established in the
scale-up process
the equipment must
perform in a way that is reliable and
repeatable so as an example for an
incubator or a freezer that means that
you have to have fast recovery from a
door opening so that the cells
are
in their ideal conditions as much as
possible to ensure proper cell growth if
you're talking about a freezer you want
fast recovery from a door opening
because even if your cells don't
literally thaw or your reagents in the
freezer
just warming up a little bit can affect
how they freeze and can affect viability
when you thaw those cells out
and that performance includes uniformity
throughout the chamber so that your
cells grow at the same rate or freeze at
the same rate
regardless of where they exist in that
incubator or that freezer
the equipment should include clear
documentation it's not just a list of
specifications but also a list of
materials of composition so that you
know
what kinds of disinfectants you can use
with that equipment
it includes performance
as i said it needs to perform in the
same way reliably and repeatedly
you need to understand the maintenance
that's required as you go through the
process as time passes by
and
everyone needs to understand the control
of that equipment you need to be able to
monitor it from across the room
the equipment needs to be easy to use
everyone using that or operating that
equipment has to understand how it works
and that extends to training and
refresher training
the equipment has to be easy to clean
i spend a lot of time talking about and
thinking about how to make laboratory
equipment easy to clean so that you
spend less time maintaining your
equipment and more time ensuring your
processes of high quality
i mentioned clear monitoring from across
the room data logging that meshes with
your building management system or your
laboratory information management system
so i've mentioned a clean room a few
times in this talk so i want to review
what is a clean room because i think
i have talked with a few people who say
well of course my laboratory is clean of
course it's a clean room but a clean
room is very different from an r d
setting so i'm going to spend some time
talking about why that is and what makes
a clean room so different
so a clean room is a controlled
environment it is an isolated room
with low levels of particulates and in
fact that a clean room is defined as a
room where the particle generation
retention and introduction are all
controlled
okay
so that's important
but how is a clean room measured how do
we measure all of those particulates in
a clean room well this is determined by
the international organization for
standardization or iso
and iso works to globally promote
industrial and commercial standards
and the air quality standards that iso
establishes are based on established
measured particle sizes and numbers and
they define a particle as a minute
physical entity piece of matter with
defined boundaries
so there are different levels of clean
rooms and i'm going to talk about that
here
so normal indoor room air is
established as iso class 9.
and so the iso room classes are
based on a log base 10 system so that
means that iso class 5
is 10 to the power of 4 or 10 000 times
cleaner than normal indoor room air at
iso class 9. and iso class 7 is 100
times less clean than iso class 5. so i
hope that makes sense and these are
defined
primarily looking at particles that are
0.5 micrometers and larger
per cubic meter of air
now you may also hear about a clean room
designated as braid b that's the most
commonly used in cell therapy
therapeutic production settings
a grade b clean room is defined as iso
class 5 when at rest
and iso class 7 when in operation
what is the difference
when the clean room is at rest or in
operation the difference is people
so people are the biggest source of
particulates in a clean room as
particles come off our hair
our breath our clothing and so people
wear specialized clothing in a clean
room
um
i guess uh grade grade a i'll just
mention grade a sometimes you'll hear
about grade a clean room the grade a
clean room is iso class 5
at rest and in operation and that's more
difficult to achieve so the more
critical the product or process the
lower the required iso rating and so
just as some examples
pharmaceutical production
is often done in iso class 7 but the
final fill and finish is done in iso
class 5.
so where do these particles come from in
a clean room and i mentioned that most
of the particles come from us
these are when we talk about microbial
contamination these are normal flora on
our hands our breasts or hair
and a study in 2008 demonstrated that
everybody all of us carry about ten
thousand microorganisms per square
centimeter on our skin so as we shed
skin cells we also shed those micro
microorganisms into the environment
microorganisms can also come from the
air
normal indoor room air at iso class 9
contains on average
between 30 and 1000 microorganisms per
cubic meter of air so this is why we
work in a biological safety cabinet when
we open
cell culture vessels to prevent
contamination entering from the air
so now i want to talk about how those
particulates impact clean rooms
and
cell therapy products
by their nature represent an inherent
risk due to the purification challenges
you can't
purify cell therapies by filtering them
because the cells themselves
that would remove the cells from the
filtration process most particulates are
much much much smaller than those
cultured cells
so when we talk about particulate
sources in the clean room the biggest
part of this pie chart seventy percent
is from the people in the clean room but
fifteen percent is coming from equipment
so
how can microorganisms come from
equipment when they're normal flora for
us and we're the biggest source of these
particulates well it turns out that
non-viable particulates are also a big
risk in a clean room and by extension
for a cell therapy so what sorts of
non-viable particles are present
these would include microscopic
particles from packaging
from glass plastic rubber stainless
steel
hair
paint and so on and those are
represented or represent a high or a
moderate risk to the cell therapy
a lower risk particulate non-viable
particulate could be cell debris
it could be
leftover materials from
reagents in the growth media for example
and these non-viable particulates also
represent a risk to the patient if they
are included in a cell therapy which
will be an injectable
and those risks include direct tissue
damage from sharp little microscopic
shards of glass or stainless steel as
examples
they could induce an immune response or
inflammation
if they get stuck in a capillary
blockage of a blood vessel for a
thrombosis or a pulmonary embolism they
can also
represent respiratory problems
so i want to put a number on some of
these risks
to the production
why is clean room compatibility an
important consideration for equipment
well here's some numbers from recent
examples so
22 percent of u.s food and drug
administration recalls of sterile
injectables between 2008 and 2012
were caused by non-viral non-viable
particulates
such as those i was just talking about
and these non-viable particulates also
represented the second leading cause of
fda recalls for the 10-year period
between 2009 and 2019.
more recently last month in japan
1.6 million doses of the modern vaccine
that were produced in spain were put on
hold due to a contamination that turned
out to be bits of stainless steel
from
production equipment in the final film
finish
room that was improperly installed
so you can see that these even these
non-viable particles coming off of
laboratory and production equipment
represent a risk they're disruptive to
the treatment
they can hinder growth of your process
and your company and obviously combating
those risks is very costly
so that's a lot about particles in a
clean room and why the clean room is
different than an r d lab
and so i hope that this shows you why a
clean room is so very much different
than the standard r d lab and why we've
been thinking about how to make a clean
room compatible co2 incubator so now i'm
going to talk about what makes a clean
room compatible co2 incubator
and why would we do that well i think
i've just shown you a lot of reasons why
but also cell therapy applications
require new solutions that comply with
these clean room standards that i was
just talking about
as i said we're shifting from an r d to
a production setting as more and more
cell therapies
go into clinical trials and approach
approval and the requirements are more
stringent obviously in a clean room
we have to provide that insurance that
these cell therapies produced in this
equipment are safe
and that means we have a heightened
focus
on audits
on regulatory on record keeping on risk
management
also in the clean room because the
environment is so rigorous there's an
intensive focus on cleaning procedures i
mentioned i think about this a lot in my
job at this point
documentation is required equipment
traceability
process control and consistency across
those processes across different lots
are critical and all of this is because
the end goal in this production is a
treatment a drug or a process that will
be used in a human patient whose health
and safety must be assured
so at this point i'm delighted to
introduce the new harrison vios cr co2
incubator which is part of our cts
series of laboratory equipment
this is based on our popular vios hair
cell bios platform
that many of you may be familiar with
and this new design focuses on what is
critical to clean room production
including particles
so this new design offers no disruption
to the clean room environment where
you're monitoring and controlling
introduction generation and retention of
particles
it also is compatible with your
processes with rigorous cleaning
procedures that you use in a clean room
and all of the features have been tested
and validated to ensure
that it will help you through your audit
process
so this incubator includes
performance with superior uniformity and
recovery and contamination control to
help keep those cells healthy and safe i
mentioned that this is based on the
existing hair cell bios platform
this incubator focuses on cleaning
i know it's unusual to show the back of
an indicator but i think this indicates
how really proud we are of this design
this design is ip54 compliant meaning
that it is resistant to ingress
of dust and dirt and droplets from
sprays
and wipe cleaning
and it is proven compatible with dry
non-condensing vhp procedures especially
that one from steris in particular and
i'll talk about that more in a bit
the entire exterior casing is brushed
stainless steel
and the interior is completely
electropolished
also there's documentation included with
this design certificates and reports are
included to support your validation and
help you ease your way through the
maintenance of this equipment
and finally it's particle controlled and
i'll talk about that more in a minute
it is certified compatible with
iso
14644 regulations and stipulations for
clean room environment it's certified
compatible with a class 5 cleanroom and
gmp grade a
and b even during standard opera
operation and sterilization modes
so how do we prevent particles in the
clean room environment when i mentioned
that 15
of those particles in a clean room come
from the equipment in that clean room
so we've designed a new active particle
controlled system where the particles in
the casing are collected
and passed through a hepa filter on the
rear of the incubator before that air is
released to the clean room and so you
see the air coming out of that hepa
filter on the right of the right photo
is indicated in a blue showing that it's
clean air released to the clean room
and then there are also four passive
intake air vents on the back and those
are indicated also you see the shorter
blue arrows where the air is coming in
to cool the electronics and replace that
outgoing air
so we validated this and how did we
validate that this design is compatible
with clean room use
we actually engaged a third-party
independent industry specialist toof in
germany and they worked in an iso class
4 clean room
and their tests showed
that
these designs are compatible with iso
class 5
and gmp grade a and b clean rooms i'm
not going to go into those tests too
much at this point
we are going to release a white paper
showing more detail on that in the
coming weeks
i will say that the evaluation was
conducted both during standard operation
up during standard operation and during
sterilization
and also all of the accessories for the
clean room were also tested
so this just shows the certificates it's
issued by tiff and you can see that they
are it says raid on the certificate
certified for incompatible for class iso
5 clean rooms and grade a and b
clean rooms
so what's all included in this incubator
one of the things we think about is
what are the questions that you have
when you're maintaining the incubator
and you're working to qualify it with
your process
so we include an installation checklist
so that you are completely informed on
the best installation procedures
iq oqpq temperature mapping documents
and help are available
you have the ability to confirm or
correct the calibration all of the
alarms and the alerts are easy to
understand and you can test them to show
during your audit process that you've
worked through those alarms and
everybody understands what they mean
we can help you with training on the
proper use
we include a routine maintenance
checklist and a spare parts list which
are critical to ensure that your
equipment doesn't go down
when you need it to be there for your
process
and responsive customer support of
course is a big part of ensuring that
your processes are uninterrupted
also this incubator comes with a
complete gmp documentation package to
support your validation and audit needs
this is unique in the industry and this
documentation package includes technical
specifications and equipment drawings
i've mentioned the preventive
maintenance lists
and the replaceable parts and all of all
of the certifications to ease your
regulatory your regulatory audits and
also there's test validation protocols
for you to do your own testing to ensure
that you understand proper operation and
the quality and operation of this
equipment
i mentioned that the accessories are
also tested and proven compatible we
offer two sizes of this incubator 165
liter and a 255 liter we've also tested
them in the stack configuration to
ensure that those particles are not
disruptive either
the stacking adapter the stand and the
roller base are all compatible and a
four to twenty milliamp output is
standard to work with your information
management systems
so i mentioned disinfectant
recommendations and how much i think
about cleaning and so we've done a lot
of testing to ensure that commonly used
disinfectants are compatible with our
incubators
i do want to take this opportunity to
say that i know all of you like to kind
of drown your equipment in the clean
room with disinfectant but it's
important to follow the manufacturer's
recommendations when you use those
disinfectants and that includes the
dwell time so if i take the spork lens
rtu steroland as an example sport
cleanse um scaris recommends a 10 minute
dwell time and at the end of that 10
minutes
you need to remove
that disinfectant because otherwise
those disinfectants build up over time
they cause pitting and corrosion of
stainless steel they can cause
cloudiness of glass doors and all of
that surface roughness provides more
places where microorganisms can attach
so it's important to remove those
disinfectants at the end of the dwell
time and the way you do that is you
follow any chemical disinfectant with
seventy percent ethanol or seventy
percent
isopropanol to remove those residues
finally please please do not ever use
bleach to disinfect your laboratory
equipment it's well known to cause
pitting and corrosion and so these on
this slide are the the disinfectants
that we would recommend for manual wipe
disinfectant disinfection of your
equipment
this incubator also features a
completely electro polished interior and
electric polishing offers a number of
benefits what electro polishing does is
it removes the surface roughness and
microscopic structure on stainless steel
and by smoothing and removing some of
that microscopic structure what that
means is that it significantly reduces
microscopic areas where microorganisms
could attach
and it improves the corrosion resistance
and eases cleaning
now many of you are using sterilization
by vaporized hydrogen peroxide in your
clean room
and that's we're seeing that a lot so we
wanted to make sure that our incubator
was compatible with these processes
i will say that a lot of companies are
offering vhp now and not all of them are
the same some of them are using
chemicals in addition to hydrogen
peroxide such as per acetic acid
and those additional chemicals can
exacerbate
pitting and corrosion
by the chemical
so
i will say that we've looked really
exclusively at the steris procedure
because
the moisture is controlled
so when you have the vapor condense
because the humidity is not controlled
that increases the dwell time of that
hydrogen peroxide and that can result
over time in again damage to the
stainless steel so we do recommend only
the steris dry non-condensing vhp
process
another part of that is that any company
that's offering this should
should offer you tests to confirm
that the process actually worked that
you have complete elimination complete
sterilization
so complete and elimination of those
microorganisms that are removed by
sterilization and finally it's important
that that vapor that gas be neutralized
and proven neutralized because hydrogen
peroxide in high concentrations
is toxic to humans and it is a known
carcinogen so that's why these
procedures are performed by trained
technicians wearing
protective personal equipment
so not everybody is using vhp processes
so this incubator also includes
an automated high temperature
sterilization the steri-run
sterilization cycle
this also has been fully validated by a
third party independent test lab
the health protection england agency
important down in the uk
we provide complete temperature maps
of 48 different locations in the
incubator chamber proving that all areas
reach the specified 180 degree
temperature throughout the chamber and
that ensures that no colder areas remain
where microorganisms could survive and
grow back
those tests performed by health
protection england were actually done
with an incubator where the
time at 180 degrees was shortened from
90 minutes to 45 minutes
so this
reduction of the approved indicator
organizations including not just the dry
heat indicator but also the biological
indicator used for autoclave
sterilization testing
and all of those were eliminated uh more
than six logs which is the requirement
for testing sterilization according to
the united states and european
pharmacopoeias all of those ten law i'm
sorry six logs or greater microorganisms
were removed in a truncated cycle such
that the production cycle where it holds
at 80 degrees 180 degrees for 90 minutes
results in a in a sterility assurance
level of 12 logs and no other
manufacturer offers this level of
security
but wait there's more
we also include an in chamber hepa
filtration so this is a little bit
different than the hepa filtration to
remove the particulates exhausted by the
incubator on the back of the incubator
this hepa filter is in the incubator
chamber
and it helps to prevent contamination
that could pose a risk to your cultured
cells while they're in the incubator
chamber
now i know there's some confusion about
hepa filtration because hepa filters are
rated for their their efficiency of
capturing 0.3 micrometer particles
that's because as indicated by this
graph that size at 0.3 is the hardest to
catch
that's because the physical processes of
diffusion which is really efficient at
catching very small particles and
impaction in interception which are
efficient at capturing larger particles
are least efficient at that medium
particle size so 0.3 micrometer
particles are captured with 99.97
efficiency but smaller and larger
particles are also captured and even
with greater efficiency so this in
chamber hepa filtration system works as
a continuous dilution
so the entire
chamber air volume is is filtered
through that hepa filter every 60
seconds so that at within five minutes
after a 30 second door opening that
chamber inside the incubator reaches iso
class 5 clean room conditions
and as you can see the air continues to
get cleaner over time as the the door
remains closed
these hepa filters snap in and out
easily you don't need any special tools
and there's an alarm to tell you to
replace it after 12 months
all right so finally i want to finish up
talking about the incubator itself
because while i spent a lot of time
talking about the clean room and why
that's challenging and why we thought a
lot about that what it really comes down
to is if your cells don't grow properly
your therapy will not be successful so i
want to spend the last minutes talking
about
incubator performance and how that
affects cell growth
so
cell culture was developed with
immortalized cell lines such as the hela
cells from henrietta lacks and those
cells have been growing in culture for
so long i call them frankenstein cells
and they can survive many challenges
that we continually torture them with in
the laboratory but for cell therapy
we're using cells that are much much
more sensitive stem cells immune cells
and primary cells and these cells are
much more reactive to what's going on
around them than these immortalized cell
lines that have mutated and adjusted to
these kind of artificial conditions in
cell culture
so cells constantly check their
surroundings they're constantly
measuring temperature humidity
gas concentration
what are are there enough nutrients in
the growth medium am i stimulated to
divide or am i
experiencing a repressor that tells me
to enter senescence am i touching other
cells or is there room for me to
multiply and they respond to these
different triggers
and so because the co2 incubator is
designed to mimic in vivo conditions
because each parameter affects cell
growth and as i just pointed out cells
respond to those changing conditions
that means that any variation in your
incubation conditions can result in
variation in your cell therapy in the
end
so i know that there are lots of
different available incubators on the
market today and it's easy to just
compare a list of specifications but
performance is more than a list of
specifications so
there may be different co2 sensors for
example that have the same
specifications in terms of their
accuracy but how that sensor performs in
incubator setting how it reacts with the
temperature and the gases and air
circulation and how many vessels are in
the incubator at a time all of that can
be different with different incubators
so i want to spend just a few minutes
looking at the different parameters
provided by the incubator how those
affect cells and why you might see
differences in different incubator
designs
so temperature of course is the place to
start and incubator temperature
obviously mimics body temperature and
cells are extremely sensitive to
temperature
most cells are okay when stored for a
few days at four degrees
so lower temperatures just kind of slow
everything down but higher temperatures
are detrimental to cells and most cells
can't withstand more than a few hours of
2 degrees celsius above their normal
temperature but for these sensitive
cells that we're talking about even a
few hours of one degree above normal
can result in cell death so
temperature is a critical component of
the incubation conditions
and i'm not going to go through this too
much because i talked about this a year
ago and you can find that talk online
but temperature recovery is very
different depending on the design of the
incubator different technologies produce
very different conditions and so as you
see the fastest recovery back to 37
degrees following a 30 second door
opening is provided by active air flow
circulation in the chamber
carbon dioxide is the second biggest
parameter provided by the incubator and
so i want to review i think many of us
don't really think about
why we provide co2 we know it's required
for cell growth and we know it's there
to balance the ph of the growth medium
but this system is actually based on the
physiological
conditions in the bloodstream and the
lung
so as this is my drawing of a blood
vessel entering a lobe of a lung and so
you see that every cell in the body is
putting out carbon dioxide as a waste
by-product of metabolism
such that the oxygen concentration in
the lungs is pretty high it's five
percent co2 that's different than the
air that we breathe which is currently
about 0.04 percent co2 so to mimic that
physiological concentration we provide
five percent co2 in the incubator most
commonly it really depends a little bit
on what what you're using for growth
medium and i'll talk about that in just
a minute
oxygen in the lungs is about 14 percent
i don't have time today to talk about
physiological oxygen
but i do want to point out that also in
the bloodstream there's a natural buffer
of bicarbonate ions and if you look at
that concentration it's equal to about
two milligrams per milliliter of sodium
bicarbonate which is the most common
buffer used in cell growth media
so if we look at that biochemistry a
little bit the buffer in the growth
medium the sodium bicarbonate works with
that co2 gas
the buffer takes up and gives off
protons to balance the ph keeping at a
physiological neutral ph of 7.4
now fluctuations in the co2
concentration can affect the morphology
and growth of your cells
if the co2 concentration is too high or
too low you'll see changes in your cells
that are reflective of toxicity because
the ph is either too acidic or too basic
so the control of the co2 is critical
and the co2 recovery to the set
conditions of five percent the most
commonly used concentration
varies very differently depending on the
different technologies included in that
incubator and again i'm not going to go
through this table because i've done it
elsewhere but just to point out that
even different sensors
that are precision can work differently
depending on the incubator design and
what's the airflow like in that
incubator
finally humidity we provide high
humidity in the incubator to reduce
evaporation from the growth media
because in low humidity water is the
only thing that evaporates from culture
media and as a result the remaining
salts minerals hormones in the growth
media become concentrated such that
toxic conditions can result so just like
too much salt in your diet is bad for
you
maybe some minerals and your vitamins
are you know if you take too many uh
multivitamins per day that can result in
toxic concentrations
that is also true
for the cells
which are derived from our tissues and
evaporation is four times faster at 80
percent humidity than at 93 percent
humidity and greater
so it's important to have high humidity
to prevent evaporation but too much
humidity is also bad so humidity higher
than about 95 approaches 100 humidity
and 100 humidity of course is rain or
fog so when the humidity is too high
that can result in condensation of that
moisture into liquid droplets or even
puddles in your incubator and that
condensation can provide a great
breeding ground for microorganisms
so proper control of humidity is
critical for healthy cells
and just like temperature and
co2 humidity recovery varies greatly
depending on the design of the incubator
and different technologies produce very
different conditions
so we like to provide a protected
integrated reservoir
for the humidity in the hair cell biocr
co2 incubator which provides
good balance but fast humidity recovery
in a dry condensation free chamber
to help provide good cell growth
but it's also very controlled and i i
know that in a lot of clean rooms
an open reservoir of water like a water
pan is frowned upon so in this incubator
the water reservoir is completely
covered and protected
the hepa filter helps to pull
contamination away from the water
finally in-chamber sensors are encrypt
are critical for proper recovery
and
accuracy of the of the temperature co2
and humidity in your cells in chamber
sensors experience the same conditions
as yourselves if you open the door you
want the sensor to react without that
condition just like your cells would
react they continuously sample and react
and adjust the conditions so that your
cells are in their ideal conditions as
much as possible and they provide better
recovery now that may seem pretty
pretty
expected for an incubator but i will
tell you that not every incubator
includes sensors in the chamber they
might be present in in a design where
samples of air from the chamber are
removed and passed to the sensor outside
the incubator chamber
uniformity throughout the chamber i've
talked about this a few times why is
this important without good uniformity
that means that cells in different areas
experience different conditions so if
you are have some cultured vessels in
the top left or some in the bottom right
of the incubator
and they there isn't good uniformity
then that can result in variability in
your results and some cells may never
experience the proper conditions
such that in the end your cell therapy
doesn't meet your quality and
characteristic analysis that is required
so
i know we think about this maybe with
temperature but i also want to point out
you know that heat rises but co2 gas is
heavier than air so it sinks
so you might have different phs in
different areas of the incubator
especially as you start to use larger
vessels for production
if you're controlling
oxygen using nitrogen gas you're working
in hypoxic conditions for stem cell
production for example nitrogen gas is
lighter than air so it rises
so
that means that active air circulation
is the only way to keep conditions
uniform throughout the incubator
so i know that sometimes you might hear
different things about a circulating fan
in the pros and cons but a circulating
fan
provides fast recovery from door opening
it ensures uniform conditions throughout
the incubator
you might hear that a circulating fan
will dry out your cultures but that
really depends on the airflow design to
make sure that the fan is not blowing
directly on your cultures
a circulating fan also that uses the
opportunity to provide hepa filtration
you can't have hepa filtration unless
you have a mechanical method for passing
the air through the hepa filter and also
a circulating fan helps to reduce
condensation so that you don't have
those puddles of humidity where
microorganisms could survive
well i've reached the end thank you for
paying attention so far let's just go
through a couple of conclusions as i
started out in the beginning i hope i
showed you that cell therapy is
projected to show double-digit growth
across all applications and sectors
as far as we've projected out through
the year 2025.
good manufacturing practices help to
ensure the safety and purity the
efficacy and quality of our cell
therapies and gmp is there is guidelines
it's not prescriptive rules but those
guidelines help define practices and
procedures and also documentation and
record management is critical for an
effective gmp process
a clean certified co2 incubator is one
that is gmp compatible
the design is proven to limit
particulates that could affect your cell
therapy that could affect your clean
road
monitoring
such design is also easy to maintain
it's compatible with common disinfection
processes
and the accessories and the complete
documentation are also compatible to
help you through your regulatory audits
finally those design and quality
components affect the performance of the
incubator and different designs affect
your end results for your cell therapies
you should ask for these performance
data from the manufacturer they are
available and you should know this and
how it's going to affect your process
at thermal scientific we've been making
co2 incubators for many decades and we
have a history of introducing
innovations to the market as you can see
on this chart
and finally if you would like more
information please visit our website at
thermofisher.com
cleanroomco2
jennifer i think i've left a
few minutes for some questions if you'd
like to open those up now
yes we have a few minutes for questions
so thank you first of all mary kay for
your informative presentation we will
now start the live q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now just click on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for let's get started
our first question here is
does the incubator show you the real
percentage of humidity in the chamber in
the display
um this particular incubator
you can control the humidity a little
bit
our goal was to provide high humidity
there's also an adjustment for lower
humidity
okay great thank you mary kay let's see
next question some labs have
uv lamps in the work room to disinfect
all the ambient
is there any inconvenience with the
equipment can uv light damage the
exterior paint
uv light does have an effect on paint
i haven't looked at that specifically
how the uv light outside the equipment
would affect it i will say that
uv light inside the incubator is not
very effective for disinfection because
of the high humidity provided by the
incubator
such that the water vapor in the air the
water droplets themselves appear to
reduce the efficacy in the reach of the
uv light that's based on a position
paper from the american biological
safety association where they said that
the efficacy of uv light drops off
precipitously in humidity above 70
percent so in the clean room itself
outside the incubator it really depends
on how high the humidity is and what's
the airflow to pass microorganisms
across that uv light and finally i would
say that the efficacy of uv light like
like many disinfection processes is
about the exposure what's the intensity
of that uv light and what's the exposure
time
so disinfection and sterilization are
time
and exposure processes right so it's
dependent not just upon the
concentration but also the exposure time
so that's something to keep in mind with
those uv lights
that the uv light is at the proper
intensity and that the exposure time is
long enough but yes that can start to
degrade some of paints
and also materials in in laboratory
equipment
thank you mary kay our next question is
can we obtain an optional shelf of
copper for effective contamination
protection
yes copper shelving is available for
these vios
co2 via cr co2 incubators
in fact you can get an optional
100 pure copper interior as well i
didn't mention that thank you for that
question
thank you mary kay the next question
i have heard that hepa filters are
expensive to replace and require special
disposal are these hidden costs for your
queen room incubator
well that is a common misconception so
hepa filters inside the incubator and on
the exhaust
are not very expensive i i tend to
equate the cost with roughly the cost of
a restriction enzyme for molecular
biology applications how much that cost
specifically will vary by your region
and your
particular vendor but
the cost is really minimal um
less than a lot of accessories for
incubators and
uh the in chamber hepa filter needs to
be replaced only once every 12 months
and the exhaust hepa filter we've rated
for replacement every six months
oh and i should mention
um
filters don't release microorganisms you
can you can just dispose of it in your
regular
biological waste
that's great thank you mary kay let's
see next question
thank you for your information on
disinfectants i see that you say one to
three percent hydrogen peroxide as a
manual disinfectant is okay what about
six percent would that be okay also
i know that everybody's urge is to use
higher and higher concentrations of
disinfectants but keep in mind that that
can affect
the
quality of your stainless steel glass
and other materials in your equipment
over time so
we tend to
stay with what's the lowest effective
dose and so we would we would probably i
guess we would absolutely recommend uh
three percent as a maximum
thank you mary kay it looks like
oh i'm sorry
um i just wanted to clarify three
percent hydrogen peroxide as a manual
disinfectant thank you jennifer
oh sure thank you so much sorry that i
interrupted looks like we have time for
one more question
since microbial contamination is a
concern for cell therapy would a copper
lined incubator be a good choice for a
clean room
yes and i i
this kind of goes back to an earlier
question where i said we do offer
optional 100 percent pure copper
interior for the vayos cr co2 incubator
the one caveat i would say is that the
copper is not compatible with vhp
processes
because it's a pure element it will
react with pretty much anything it
touches which is why
it's so effective in controlling
contamination
and as a result of that the high high
concentrations of hydrogen peroxide
can
start to degrade the copper over time
and it can remove the protective patina
that develops which also increases the
efficacy of the copper and strengthens
the copper itself so
for using copper in a clean room
um remember that the copper itself
replaces disinfectants because it's so
effective at eliminating microorganisms
but
we would recommend to use 70 ethanol or
70 isopropanol just to ensure that the
copper remains clean you can use mild
dish soap
on a you know impregnated cloth in the
clean room and then follow that with 70
ethanol or 70 isopropanol but i would
recommend strongly to stay away from
those stronger disinfectants which are
not needed for copper interiors in any
case
thank you mary kay do you have any final
comments for our audience today
just thanks everyone for attending and
staying this long i know we are all busy
and especially as we work to extend our
cell therapies to production setting
time is always of the essence
when you're under the gun for getting
things up and running so thank you for
staying this long and um
i guess good luck with your developing
therapeutics
thank you again mary kay for your time
today and for your important research we
would also like to thank labrus and our
sponsor thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye